the journey of a thousand miles
begins with a single step
if you are depressed
you are living in the past
if you are anxious
you are living in the future
if you are at peace
you are living in the present
when i let go of what i am
i become what i might be
watch your thoughts
they become your words
watch your words
they become your actions
watch your actions
they become your habits
watch your habits
they become your character
watch your character
it becomes your destiny
knowledge is the treasure
and practice is the key to it
life is a series of natural and
spontaneous changes
don't resist them
that only creates sorrow
let reality be reality
let things flow naturally forward and
whatever way they like
those who know do not speak
those who speak
do not know
time is a created thing
to say i don't have time is like saying
i don't want to
care about what other people think
and you will always be their prisoner
[Music]
there is no crime greater than having
too many desires
there is no disaster greater than not
being content
there is no misfortune greater than
being
covetous
the truth is not always beautiful
nor beautiful words the truth
be content with what you have
rejoice in the way things are
when you realize there is nothing
lacking
the whole world belongs to you
we gain by losing
lose by gaining
[Music]
the snow goose need not bathe to make
itself white
neither need you do anything
but be yourself
the wise man
is one who knows
what he does not know
what the caterpillar calls the end
the rest of the world
calls a butterfly
i have just three things to teach
simplicity
patience
compassion
these three are your greatest treasures
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength
while loving someone deeply gives you
courage
new beginnings are disguised as painful
endings
so the unwanting soul sees what's hidden
and the ever-wanting soul sees only what
it wants
health is the greatest possession
contentment is the greatest treasure
confidence
is the greatest friend
[Music]
success is as dangerous as failure
hope
is as hollow as fear
feel you're a bowl to the brim and it
will spill
keep sharpening your knife
and it will blunt
he who is satisfied
with his lot is rich
what is a good man but a bad man's
teacher
what is a bad man but a good man's job
[Music]
because one believes in oneself
one doesn't try to convince others
because one is content with oneself
one doesn't need others approval
because one accepts oneself
the whole world accepts him or her
a man with outward courage dares to die
a man with inner courage
dares to live
if you aren't afraid of dying there is
nothing you can't achieve
nature does not hurry
yet
everything is accomplished
to recognize your insignificance is
empowering
sometimes you must yield in order to win
and sometimes maintaining a low place
leads you to win
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments one
day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity watch our next video